we want people to hear and understand
what happened to some of these folks
oh my Robert Morton yes it was lynched
for writing a note to a white woman yes
David hunter was lynched in Lauryn
County South Carolina for leaving the
farm where he worked without permission
yeah that's Oprah Winfrey an attorney
Bryan Stevenson last night on 60 minutes
exploring a new tribute that honors
thousands of victims of lynching it is
featured at Stevenson's new memorial for
peace and justice in Montgomery Alabama
the memorial is accompanied by the
Legacy Museum it chronicles the eras of
racial injustice Stevenson labels from
enslavement to mass incarceration both
the memorial and the museum will open to
the public on April 26th Michelle Miller
visited the museum and spoke with
Stevenson and a man whose personal story
is featured in the exhibit Michelle good
morning good morning
well Bryan Stevenson spent 16 years
fighting to free Anthony ray Hinton who
was on death row for nearly three
decades for crimes he did not commit
Stevenson says that out of all of his
clients Hinton has inspired him the most
and in hopes of changing the fate of
others Hinton is sharing his account of
nearly being executed do you know when
that day may have come it was coming
soon if God hadn't in vain and sent me
his best lawyer within two years I would
have gotten an execution date when I
would get out of my car and start
walking to the prison guards would start
pulling me aside when you get ray out
really oh yeah how could they believed
he was innocent they believed he was in
it they knew that he was innocent
despite his innocence Anthony ray Hinton
lingered on death row for nearly 30
years he tells his story here at the
legacy museum created by his attorney
Bryan Stevenson I think the first person
perspective is key the museum chronicles
racial injustice from enslavement to
mass incarceration the theory behind
this space is really the evolution
slavery slavery then becomes lynching
and lynching becomes codified
segregation and now we're in an era of
mass incarceration well we're still
indifferent to the plight of people of
color
no country incarcerates more people than
the United States out of those on death
row forty-one percent or black the equal
justice initiative estimates that one
out of 10 of those sentenced to death
are innocent it's a reality Hinton has
experienced firsthand
he said there's five thing that going to
convict you would you like to know what
they are I said yes
Henson says those were the words of the
detectives who arrested him when he was
falsely identified for the murders of
two fast-food workers in 1985 he said
number worn you black number two old
white man he's gonna say you shot him
whether you shot him or not he said
believe me I don't care he said number
three you gonna have a white prosecutor
number four you gonna have a white judge
and number five more than likely you're
gonna have an all-white jury he said do
you know what that spell and he repeated
the word conviction conviction
conviction conviction conviction
Stevenson took on his case fifteen years
later
discovering a botched defense mishandled
evidence and a refusal by Alabama's
highest court to admit a mistake had
been made in his trial but in 2015 the
US Supreme Court recognized the
injustice ruling unanimously to
exonerate Hinton thirty years ago
prosecution seen being to take my life
for me his story and others like it are
the last stop on the museum's journey
they just picked this phone yes they
listened to his story why was it so
important that Anthony Rae hiddens story
be part of this museum because you can't
understand this history without
understanding what we were doing to
people like Anthony Rea Hinton if we had
confronted the legacy of slavery if we
had confronted the ideology of white
supremacy and the narrative of racial
difference at the end of the Civil War
Anthony buddy hinten wouldn't have ended
up on death row if we had put down the
signs that said segregation forever not
just in our minds within our hearts we
wouldn't have put that man on death row
for thirty years but because we didn't
we have a system of justice now where
there are thousands of Anthony Rey
Hinton's still languishing in jails in
prison there are nearly 3,000 people
currently on death row Hinton lists each
by name at the end of his new memoir the
Sun does shine he knows not all of them
are innocent but says they all deserve
humanity I want people to realize that
we can teach hate but we also can teach
love and so as I look around this museum
I see a lynching a man that was lynched
for nothing but the color of his skin
it's sad but they died for a reason and
sometime
some of us have to pay a bigger price
than others and if their price for me to
spend 30 years and at 5x7 pure Hill
every day so be it
Hinton sat down with Scott Pelley back
in 2016 following his release and he
told him that he had not received any
compensation or even an apology from the
state of Alabama he informed us that now
three years after his release he still
hasn't received any money or an apology
Hinton's book the Sun does shine how I
found life and freedom on death row is
available now where books are sold
that's disgraceful
he just received no compensation I just
started reading that book over the
weekend not only that he passed a
polygraph test as you know and his
supervisor at the time said that he
clocked in that he was there on the job
and he still was convicted it is a
process in pattern he says and Brian
Stevenson says that happens to so many
people they just get railroaded so the
question is how do you change the
criminal justice system in particular
one out of ten people are deemed
innocent at least by egi and
and how do you have a death penalty when
you know that innocent people are on
death roster hiddens amazing man it's an
amazing story
well three decades stolen from an
innocent man yes but what do you said
you can teach people to hate you can
also teach people to love and that's his
point in the price of he is helping
people and he really wants to get back
to the reason to help other people yeah
thank you good book thank you